that's for you okay I'd like to actually
try this inverted just to make this even
more impossible there we go this is
going to work a treat why Christopher
Nolan now that in and of itself is just
a question if you take a little bit of
that why Christopher Nolan doesn't use
CGI I find CGI however versatile it is
but it always tends to feel a little
safe to me I think if you want something
to have a bit of bite you've got the
imagery to have a bit of threat even if
it's a miniature even if it's something
very fake but something real on camera I
think it gives you a better result why
does Christopher Nolan we're in the wise
shoot on film I shoot a film because
it's the highest quality Imaging format
of a device particularly IMAX film large
format film but film uh shows you the
world kind of the way your eye sees it
is it ridiculous for me to give a
serious answer well yeah but this is why
give the people what they want